[Music]
play the board not me patience oh yeller
checkmate
hey guys yup we got exposed daniel park
bad day to go to the park i guess it's a
custom job i don't think this is the end
game
we save uit how can i help my internet
has passed away let's see if we can't
bring that back to life
you will die today unless you do exactly
as you're told
it's military pressure sensitive
two floors up bankers hedge fund crooks
i want you to rob them
do i have your attention now orlando or
should i call you
red knight that was your hacker handle
wasn't it i've been out of the game a
long time now
i want to own
the owners you want your servers you're
crazy if i get caught i'm facing 20.
time for the confession
my name is orlando fryer i am the person
responsible for the bombing in the park
and hudson towers
you got a family it won't be the first
cycle with kids i just want to weigh our
ocean before we orphan his baby
it's about to get a whole lot hotter
why do you care about his family i don't
other than a hacker ain't a bomber
get our eye on this guy i'm in position
building wired to blow up
maybe orlando's a patsy tick tock tick
tock tick tock tick tock swat prep for
assault red all hands on deck
what have you done
who knows how many more could die
you got a dead man switch ready to blow
we're picking up another heat signature
life or death you
choose in the hot seat now
in this now or we'll end it for him no
time is running come on
[Music]
you